presidents are paid $400,000 a year and
they can't refuse their salaries
according to the Constitution but they
can do whatever they want with the money
once it's been paid to them Donald Trump
is the richest man ever to be President
of the United States he has talked about
donating his salary
Trump's presidency as sort of a
volunteer job not exactly the kind of
volunteer work I think of when I think
about what benefits society but okay
finally after some question about
whether Trump is or isn't really going
to donate a salary we've learned he's
going to donate a salary to the National
Park Service Donald Trump is donating
his first quarter paycheck of seventy
eight thousand three hundred and thirty
three dollars to the National Park
Service here is the ever eloquent Sean
Spicer talking about this the president
has spoken with counsel and and made the
decision to donate his first quarter
salary in total to a government entity
and he has chosen this quarter to to
donate it to the National Park Service
there's my pleasure on behalf of the
president United States to resent a
check for seventy eight thousand three
hundred and thirty three dollars to the
Secretary of the Interior Ryan Zinke and
superintendent of the Harpers Ferry Park
sites superintendent Brandenburg so
that's great right the questions about
is Trump really going to donate his
salary those questions have been
answered
Trump's donating to a program that he
finds worthwhile the National Park
Service of course the reality is that
seventy eight thousand dollars pales in
comparison to the 1.5 billion with a be
budget cut the Donald Trump is proposed
for the Department of the Interior which
oversees the National Park Service
Spicer originally said Trump would be
donating a salary at the end of the year
to a charity of the press course choice
it's pretty clear why that changed and
decided to do this instead apparently
trying to save some face after badly
misallocating federal funds in his
proposed budget and look at the guy's
face this is the superintendent of the I
think they said the Harpers Ferry right
look at the guy's face as he's being
holding this check he seems to know the
political BS that's going on here don't
you think Pat doesn't exactly look
thrilled about what's happening they can
tell but I think the public will
consider Donald Trump to be charitable
and actually someone who supports the
National Park Service choice they may
see this photo-op and not realize that
the presidential budget wants to cut the
Department of interior's budget by so
much 1.5 billion dollars of course part
of that for the National Park Service at
the press conference
Spicer went on about just how great and
how important the National Park Service
is but it's not important enough not to
get 1.5 billion cut from the department
that handles its funding such a kind
gesture maybe next quarter Trump will
put the 78k towards that Mexican wall
that will cost tens of billions of
dollars because you know every dollar
counts seventy eight thousand dollars
could pay for what I'm what would that
even pay for a one one piece a piece of
rebar or whatever it is or maybe a
salary or two that's about it yeah it
would pay for a few months salary for a
couple of the workers that would be
working on it
today's program is made possible in part
by Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com
/td PS